good go deep I got it I got it all right
that was a good catch right there well I
mean you kind of popped that one up
really easy for me
all right well enough about baseball
what do you have for us today ID so
today we're gonna talk about this do
this do what's up
so a steel provides an instructive view
over your service mission oh I don't
know what a service message is can you
explain it to me yeah a service mesh
describes your micro services and the
applications and their interactions hey
steel helps you with the traffic
management observability and security
steel helps in the coupling your
application code from the Pat form and
policy controls if you're the GM and
kubernetes is a manager it cos you're
hitting pinching and bench coaches all
right great so how do I set it up let's
jump right in let's do it
so the first thing that we're gonna do
here is we're going to just check to
make sure that requester is up and
running and now we are going to create
the cluster admin goals so that we can
create our back rules for SEO now we're
going to download the latest release of
SEO and it'll take a little bit of time
for us to get here and go download it
now that it's downloaded we're going to
uncompress it and we're going to enter
the folder so now that we've entered the
folder we're gonna set our path so that
we can run the SEO control and now we're
going to deploy SEO core components
using the pre created yellow files so
this is running through so this yellow
file creates the SEO system namespace
the are back permissions and installs
all the components for us so now once we
have that set up and running we're going
to configure and set up the system for
automatic sidecar injection well setup
the config mapping and then create a key
pair for the web hugs once this is done
we will set the CA bundle in the webhook
install yamo file and we will install
the injector webhook so this will give
us the ability here whenever we deploy
an application with labeled namespace we
can actually have the SDO sidecar
automatically injected just take a
little bit more here to install the last
little bit so now we're gonna just go
real quick and just supply this file
that we've been updating to push it all
on to have this running perfectly so now
that that's all good what we're gonna do
here is we're gonna label our default
namespace so that any application that
we deploy in our default namespace will
get an sto sidecar injected so now we're
just gonna check to make sure that that
labels been added and now we can see
here our labels been added to the system
and now here let's let's just go through
and let's check out a sample application
a simple hello world application that
responds back with what version it's
running so let's go here and let's just
very simply apply and deploy this
application to verify that the
Injection is working so now what we'll
do is here we're gonna run the cube CTL
get pods and just check the status to
make sure that the pods are up and
running and they are up and running wow
that was really easy you must've hit
that one out of the park
yeah setting up ISTE on gke is easier
than stealing a base I don't know
baseball but please make sure to LIKE
share and subscribe to this video and if
you're working on something cool and
want to reach out to us click on the
description below
[Music]